Louis Blouin, nous l'explique.
- Good morning M. Sloly.
Are you de scapegoat in this
story?
- Morning folks.
- Fébrilité et tension pour
l'un des témoignages les plus
attendus de la commission.
Un ancien chef visiblement
nerveux, montré du doigt
pour sa gestion de la crise
des camionneurs.
Il compare l'arrivée
du convoi, le premier week-e
à un coup de poing.
Son corps de police dégarni
a été surpris par l'ampleur
du mouvement.
Ému, Peter Sloly, explique
que ses agents ont fait
de leur mieux dans des
circonstances inhumaines.
"Il faisait trop froid,
dit-il, et c'était trop."
Malgré les avertissements dans
les rapports de renseignements,
Peter Sloly s'attendait
à une manifestation
d'un week-end seulement.
Il reproche aux autorités
fédérales de ne pas lui avoir
assez fourni de renseignements
sur ce mouvement d'une ampleur
nationale.
(klaxons)
Quand on lui demande
s'il avait les pouvoirs
légaux d'empêcher les camions
d'entrer dans la ville...
"Je ne suis pas un avocat",
répond-il.
Peter Sloly a été appelé
à expliquer une déclaration
controversée.
"Il n'y a pas de solution
policière à la crise",
disait-il le 2 février.
"Il fallait aussi
engager la société civile
et les trois ordres de
gouvernement", a-t-il précisé.
Peter Sloly reconnaît
qu'il y a eu des retards
et de la confusion dans
la réponse du haut commandement
de la police d'Ottawa.
Mais il minimise
sa responsabilité.
Combatif, il nie avoir été
inflexible ou avoir retardé
l'intervention en ,
par exemple, à la négociation
avec les manifestants.
"C'est une invention,
un mensonge", a-t-il martelé.
Mais au plus fort de la crise,
quand son autorité était remise
en question, jamais Peter Sloly
ne reconsidérer céder les rênes
à un autre corps policier.
En 30 ans, il n'a jamais vu ça.
(en anglais)
Pour Peter Sloly, l'heure
n'était pas au mea culpa.
Après avoir été ciblé par
tant de critiques, l'ancien chef
enfin riposter et donner
sa version des faits. Il refuse
de porter la responsabilité
de cette débâcle. Mais pour lui,
le combat n'est pas terminé,
son contre-interrogatoire qui
commence lundi s'annonce corsé.
Ici Louis Blouin,
Radio-Canada, Ott